You know, everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
Both Mabbie and beautiful weather where you're at.
It is, it is growing in up here.
We have a record about a snowfall this year.
Feel like, when I was a kid, since we had this much snow,
so it's great.
All right, let's get started.
Some really good news.
If you haven't been on the member site,
we can now do Cheekswam testing again.
So we settled everything with the state board,
and they had nothing to say about Cheekswam testing.
We still cannot do one-on-one calls.
And our attorney said, this is going to cross the board
with, our attorney is pretty big with attorney
with dealing with these things
with doctors across the country.
And she said, this is the way really every clinic
that you're, if you're doing any kind of business,
state-to-state-to-state, you know, across the nation,
you have got to go to the group Zoom calls.
That's where you're going to be safest.
You can't do one-on-one calls.
That constitutes practicing medicine within that state.
And you're just going to get yourself in trouble.
And so, but as far as doing Cheekswam testing,
doing kinesiology, there's no governing board against that.
That doesn't fall within the medical perspective
nor the car-practic perspective.
So you don't need to be licensed, you know,
natural apathy or anything like that
in order to do Cheekswam kinesiology testing.
So we're safe to do that.
Yay, EAP, thanks for all your prayers.
I really appreciate that.
So back to Cheekswams again, it's all up on the member site.
So make sure that on the member site,
you please, you know, fill out the Cheekswam request form
so that I know what you want me to test for.
And you can test for right-updating.
You could test, we could go back,
you know, testing for protocols and everything.
We want to leave all those expanded protocols up there
because I just believe there's some great information
there for you to use.
So if pain for Cheekswam test is, you know,
not in your budget right now,
you can utilize those expanded protocols
that we could talk about.
We're going to go back to a Monday Zoom call.
I don't know if it's going to be next Monday
or the Monday following that.
I will have that information up on the member site
for you in the next few days.
So all good news.
Back to being able to do the Cheekswam falls
within our legal right to do that.
So that's where, you know,
we just got that information.
So praise God for that.
Many of you have emailed me personally and asked about,
you know, where could you complain
about this stupid tyrannical government
trying to take over your healthcare system?
Really, this is state board issues.
And the state boards are governed by no one.
So the way your state medical board
or car practic board works in literally every state
is the president of the board is appointed by the governor.
And it's an appointee.
One of those types of appointees
that never really change it.
So if you have a complete change in government
because the people elected a Republican
or an independent or a Democrat,
they almost never change the appointees
like the car practic board or the naturopathic board
or the medical board.
That's just that those people are in for a life position.
The problem is is that they are judging jury.
So they can pull, if you're licensed,
if you're licensed to practice medicine or car practic,
let's say the state of Iowa
and they get a complaint against you,
they can pull you in and basically
break you over the poles and you really don't have,
you can do anything you want.
That was the issue when I was licensed in Minnesota.
That's why I get rid of my car practic license in Minnesota.
I got called before the board
at least a dozen times.
Accused me of things I didn't do.
I showed them proof that it's just to make a difference
if they don't like you and they didn't like
what I was doing with right technology
and what how we were helping people.
They just tore me up and down and finally eventually said,
you don't do in car practic,
get rid of your stupid car practic license
and function under your pest or medical association license.
These guys are wicked and that's what we did back in 2012.
But I have stuff against me, the car practic board
because of those things because we were helping cancer patients
back in 2005.
So it's just insane.
It's better off not being licensed,
but then the medical boards are going against
non-licensed practitioners and saying
that they're practicing medicine with no license.
So it's insane.
So we can continue to do cadetiology
that does not fall within medical or car practic
or an antropathic guidelines.
Oh, enough of that.
Just a reminder, make sure that you understand
that we had to pull because of practicing medicine, right?
We pulled all our blogs off our public site,
which I think is better.
I want that this information just to be for you guys.
So now I'd have to worry about
I could start putting up blog posts
about also lots of different stuff.
Not worried about any repercussions from the medical field
because they're not going to be visible except by you.
So make sure that you're looking at this little icon
on the member's site.
And you can't see it on your phone.
You have to go to a desktop, try to get that fixed,
so that you can look up information, whatever you need.
Now to your questions, a lot of them.
I listen to your talk on the summit.
You mentioned the generational damage
because we were bored with bad genes.
Are those things that can be repaired with healthy lifestyle
and future offspring will be okay, plus ourselves
or can it never be reversed?
Well, there are practitioners out there that say
that you can change your genes
by taking these supplements or doing these different things,
but you can't, I just totally disagree with that.
I'm open to it, show me the proof.
It's really easy to retest the person's genes.
And if you change that person's genetic picture,
then great.
There's never ever been the proof that that happens.
Once you have a genetic gene defect,
you are going to pass that on to your progeny.
And that's the way it is.
We were able to go back in time
through some sort of magical apparatus
and test our ancestors.
I will guarantee you that they did not have
the same number of defects that we have.
So what causes our genetic defects is we inherit genetic defects
from our parents.
So if they have a double allele defect,
you're going to inherit at least a single allele defect.
Secondly, you acquire defects because of toxins.
So you're exposed to benzines,
you're exposed to pesticides,
you're exposed to different chemicals
that can affect those defects in cause and defect
in your acetic or P450 or Pondland pathways.
And now, if you have children after that point in time
that you caused that defect,
you could inherit that defect from you.
In your book on cancer,
you included an interview with Dr. Gonzalez
on enzyme treatment of cancer.
Dr. Gonzalez said that he believes
most over the counter enzymes don't work
for his type of cancer treatment.
How do you know that?
Digestives, X, fermented enzymes in pancreatic,
8x plus enzymes do work.
Dr. Gonzalez also mentioned that they were involved
at an NCI funded FDA approved randomized trial
of Clevver universally, what was the outcome?
I don't know if he finished that trial
before he passed away.
So he passed away a number of years ago
from the parent heart attack.
There's people out there that say that he was murdered
with conspiracy theory.
I don't know if it's true or not,
or we have all know that so many of our conspiracy theories
have become realities.
I don't know about that one,
but Dr. Gonzalez was very much
a believer Dr. William Kelly's work.
So Dr. William Kelly really wrote the book
on enzyme therapy.
Dr. Gonzalez kind of took up that torch
and followed Dr. William Kelly's work exclusively.
So his belief, and at the time really
of my interview with him is that he believed
that the best enzymes were the pancreatic pork enzymes,
which are the pancreatic 8x enzymes, okay?
So this is the pancreatic 8x enzyme
that you're talking about here really is the same thing
as what Dr. Gonzalez used.
Dr. Gonzalez used a brand of enzymes
that we also carry, that's called,
that's from allergy research company,
and they are their call, paycreatic pork enzymes.
That's what they're called.
And they are less expensive than digestimes plus,
but they're less powerful.
So the digestimes plus are more powerful.
And that's through, I believe that whole heart of the,
if Dr. Gonzalez was alive today,
he would probably be using the digestimes plus
because the biggest struggle with using
the allergy research brand,
pancreatic pork enzymes is you literally
are need to be taking 75 of them
in the morning and 75 of them in the evening.
Now that's very difficult to take that many
for anybody, even if you're super healthy
to be swallowing that many enzymes.
And that was the compliance issue,
was it issue that Dr. Gonzalez spoke about quite often
that was a huge issue for helping people.
The digestimes plus fermented are more powerful enzymes
you could take far less.
That's the benefit.
Paycreatic A-DEX is really the same thing as this.
It's just a different company that makes these
than the allergy research.
Kinesiology is a quarter showed of
determined customized protocols for your members.
Okay, well, this came in after before.
Yeah, we don't have to worry about this anymore
because we're going to be doing that testing.
So other legal restrictions and strategy.
So we've considered everything.
And when we heard back from our attorney
that we feel very comfortable
when we forward with being able
to do cheek swab testing again.
So that's very good news.
Okay, this question.
I remember Ann or Michelle telling me
about an alternative to pet scans here in Twin Cities.
One that does not use radioactive sugar
or something like that are digging through the emails.
Okay, so an alternative to pet scans,
an alternative to MRI is this company right here,
the pre-new vote.
Pre-new vote is a new type of MRI.
It actually interviewed this doctor on our
Dr. Cutter's clinic live a couple of years ago.
This was the last scan I did for my cancer.
Now they have these units in vocal rotund,
Dallas, Los Angeles, Minneapolis,
it's actually out in,
wasn't that I went to say this park area.
Silicon Valley,
the Vancouver, British Columbia.
So they have several more that they're hoping to refurbish
because they're taking MRI units
and they're doing adding some technology to them
to be able to give a much better picture than an MRI.
It's kind of like an MRI,
the CT scan, the pet scan, all had a baby.
You get a pre-new vote scan.
The only negative is they're not covered under insurance,
but they're trying to make them affordable for people.
I think a full body pre-new vote scan is like $2,500.
I don't, I think it's somewhere out there.
I can't remember because mine was a year to half ago now.
Was it?
Yeah, and so this is what you want to look at pre-new vote.
And they do not use any gadolinium dyes,
they don't use, that's the benefit.
And it gives a better scan image
than if they did an MRI with gadolinium.
So it's a really good imaging.
I have breast cancer that has metastasized to the bones
by tumor markers are going down.
Can you explain how this relates to the body metastasis?
Well, typically if your tumor markers are going down,
that's typically an indication
that your cancer is call me down,
that you're not getting as much growth.
It's not a perfect representation,
but it is one sign that we're moving in the right direction.
So does the decreased tumor markers have anything to do
with the regression of bones?
So it doesn't have anything to do
whether your bones are healing, doesn't have anything to do
with how much damage you have in your bones,
but it has to do it.
The cancer is, cancer growth is decreasing.
But you do have to, it's like any other test,
it's just one test.
So you have to weigh that with other tests.
So the number one test with metastasis
would be a PET scan and a CT scan.
So you'd want to look at that.
Also look at alkaline phosphatase
that we talked about alcohol and phosphatase.
Last week and I said, you know,
alkaline phosphatase, that's one test that you'd have done
with a complete metamolic panel.
That's typically considered a liver marker,
but it will be elevated with
a bony metastasis,
because you'll get a lytic attack on the bone
and break out of the bone
and that will elevate alkaline phosphatase.
So it elevates with metastasis to bode.
So let's say you did know you had any metastasis to the bone
and your alkaline phosphatase was elevated.
You'd want to at least look at that.
The number one reason why alkaline phosphatase
will be elevated is not bony metastasis.
It's liver congestion
and the number one reason for that
is a reaction to medication.
So even a healthy medication
that might be killing your cancer
certainly is congested your liver
and certainly can be the is still the number one cause
that elevated liver markers,
A-S-T-A-L-T, and an alkaline phosphatase.
By right fog, it's very warm, almost hot.
Is this normal?
Yes, that's normal.
That's why it has a little hole in them.
The new ones do for the last year and a half
to have a little hole to help dissipate that heat.
Also, I feel my bones popping.
Is it something that it is something that is new?
It's not painful.
Have you heard of this?
I'm not sure what you mean by bones popping.
I don't think that has anything to do with the right machine.
I've not heard of that.
I'll be traveling for 10 days soon
and what are you about flying with the right machine?
Is it typical OK to travel with?
Yes.
You should have no trouble traveling with it.
You can carry it.
It's carrying case.
If you do that, I would.
Bring it as a carry on.
Not I would not check it.
But I put my right machine and wrapped it in a sweatshirt.
Put it in my baggage and checked my luggage, no problem.
And I brought it in on my carry, no trouble.
I've never brought the big plastic case.
I've always to conserve space,
wrapped it in a sweatshirt or something like that
and put it in my travel bag.
When I brought it as a carry on, most of the time,
they will pull you aside and they will look at it.
When they x-ray it, it doesn't look like a bomb,
but they may think what's this.
And sometimes they just look at it and just swap it down
and let you go.
And sometimes they've asked me, what's this?
And I say it's a right machine and then they look at me
and they shake their head and they swap it down
and give it back to me.
I'm training my lap breast with black sand.
I'll be receiving chemo soon.
Should I discontinue the use of black sand?
There's no reason for you to discontinue the use of black sand
just because you're doing chemo.
It isn't functioning as an antioxidant,
so there's no reason for you to do that.
If you want to just discontinue it to give yourself a break,
there's nothing wrong with that.
I cleaned the wool daily with hydrogen peroxide
to remove a white film from the area while cleaning.
Should I continue to clean it to remove the film
or let it heal?
If so, what's the typical healing process
in a removing the tissue by cleaning?
Yes, I think you should continue to clean it
like that.
Don't wipe it too hard, but to continue to spray
on hydrogen peroxide or that hydrogen peroxide
flow over it into the sink or into the shower
is the right thing to do.
I would continue to clean it if you're
going to continue to use the black sand.
Two weeks prior to chemo, the protocol
recommends phosphatidal colline, which
is body-vial PC2 capsules a day.
When do you recommend to stop taking this?
The day of chemotherapy?
Well, actually, you can take, technically,
you can still take phosphatidal colline
right through chemotherapy.
The purpose of taking phosphatidal colline
is that's the precursor for bile.
It will help bile production.
Phosphatidal colline is also what is all your cell membranes.
It's a nutrient that all your cell membranes
use to make the cells in the cell membrane.
It's good for brain function.
But biggest reason why we recommend it
is for detox pathway to help make bile.
Really, you can take that through chemo therapy.
It's not an antioxidant.
So it's not something you have to discontinue.
Day before chemo, the protocol says no sun
has no antioxidants.
Correct.
Our coffee enemas OK the day before.
Yes, you can.
Technically, you could do coffee enemas
throughout the whole time, too.
They're not functioning as an antioxidant.
They're just helping with detoxification.
But if you want to be on the real safe side, just 48 hours
after you do the chemo, then I would just stay away from that.
Because Ibraids treat the metastasis to bone cancer
from the breast.
Well, I can't really say Ibraids does or does not do anything.
But if the Ibraids is effectively killing the cancer,
it will, should effectively kill the cancer.
That's metastasized anywhere in your body.
Because if you have metastasis to the bone, remember,
it's still breast cancer.
It's not bone cancer.
It's still breast cancer.
So if you have prostate cancer that metastasized to the bone,
it's not bone cancer, it's prostate cancer.
So just keep that in mind and that will help you work through that.
Can you help me interpret this?
It looks like some good news, bad news from retesting that.
So when you guys look at your CT scans and stuff,
whether try to figure out if it's getting better
or getting worse on a CT scan, I think you're in the right
when you're OK.
So this is, let's look right here.
So this says this area is talking about this first mass.
Here's this size and it measured this size before.
So this is better.
It's gotten smaller.
Here's this second mass.
It's this size now and it was this size before.
So it's gotten smaller.
So that's good.
And then you go, this one is this size now.
Previously measured this.
So this is where it gets a little sketchy
because of the previous measurement didn't
give you a three-dimensional measurement.
And like we referred to somebody
talked about at the last Zoom call,
is that if you don't get it done at the same place
read by the same radiologist, there's
a lot of subjective interpretation of these things.
And different CT scans give you
different objective determinations.
So just because this is gold standard,
doesn't that mean it isn't really anything
close to gold standard?
So what you're really looking for in re-scans,
like you could say, oh, yeah, look at it.
It's gotten smaller.
Woo, that's fantastic.
Well, yeah, but you're within a range of error
here.
And not to burst your bubble that it hasn't gotten smaller.
Well, that's great.
But you're still within a range of error here.
Really what you're looking for when you do a re-skid,
you don't want it to go double in size or something.
Like this one down here, measure this before.
Well, that's gotten bigger.
Still within the range of error,
you're talking about four millimeters here.
So this one looks like this one is OK, this one's stable.
So you're really looking for if it was this size before,
4.7 by 4.4 by 3.7.
And it's now 7.7 by 6.4.
It's gotten considerably bigger.
Anything within five millimeters,
it's just you're way within the range of error.
So if this was me and this was my cancer,
I would be very happy with the way I'm going right now.
You should be elated, not that you don't
want to try new things or try different things.
I certainly wouldn't scuttle my, you know, like crude protocol.
I think you're certainly putting the brakes on things here.
So it's not growing.
Remember, we talked about, if your cancer's not, you know,
actively growing, you know, that's good news.
It's not acting like a cancer right now.
You've got to keep it that way, but this is very good news
or a court here.
Is it OK to use the right jackhammer application as an add-on?
So we've spoken about this many times.
Yes, you can use the jackhammer, really the jackhammer,
increases the output.
That's why it's an amplification literally.
And so you'll have more power.
Really the use of the jackhammer is daytime use
if the bulb is several feet away from you.
At night, when you have the bulb and you're
snuggling with it, you don't need the jackhammer,
but you can use it if you want.
Prior to being diagnosed with squamous cell carcinoma
tonsils, I was having post-nasal drip, which
was causing sleep apnea.
I bought a Navage machine, which I've used in daily.
And I think these Navage machines I don't have one,
but I think they're great.
Helps keep my side.
This is clear.
However, sometimes during the day,
then always overnight, I continue to manufacture mucus
that comes down my throat, cause me to cough.
But muscle tested for allergy, bacteria, viruses,
as it's worse than before.
Could this be from detoxing, from using my protocol?
It could be.
I don't think it's from detoxing them.
Lots of practitioners want to use that as an excuse
for symptoms, really, most of the time that's not.
There's no real rash at all for them.
I think it's because whether you are taking
a lot of immune stimulation, and you're using the rife
to help kill your cancer, you're stimulating
your immune response against that cancer,
you are going to produce more mucus.
You are going to produce, because mucus
is a function of histamine production, which
is a pre-immune function stimulation.
You're producing histamine and other immune pre-immune cytokines
to stimulate immune system attack on something.
So that's why, if you have an allergy,
you're going to produce a lot of histamine,
because an allergy stimulates your body
thinks that you're having an immune attack on something,
and it's stimulating that pre-immune response.
So I think you don't want to stop that.
When we're killing cancer, you're
using a bunch of immune stimulation to help attack your cancer.
So that's not something we want to stop.
Now, I would agree that you're using,
I've been drinking slippery L.T., and sage, and honey,
but I want to eliminate the source of the mucus.
I think the source of the mucus
is that you're purposely trying to stimulate your immune system.
So I don't know that you certainly don't want to stop that.
But certainly taking things that will decrease cytokine formation,
which would be like curcumin, green T-extract,
things that we talked about over and over
that will help decrease inflammatory cytokines.
So the curcumin, the EGCG from green T-extract, the corsetin,
and stinging nettle, things like that,
are really, you're going to be your goal, too, things.
Any recommendations or eggs in the,
as I have several spots on my back and nothing seems to help
was whether if rife could help with this under one of the programs.
I know there is a program for eczema with the rife
in the past.
Historically, I've used laser-unpeople for eczema with a lot of help.
So if you can find a practitioner that has laser therapy,
I would give that a shot, too.
How could I get my lymphocytes up?
So your lymphocytes are one of your white blood cells.
So everything that you're doing to stimulate your immune response
is going to be helping raise your lymphocytes.
There isn't anything specific, nutritionally,
that would be like, oh, just start doing this.
You are already doing a bunch of stuff to help stimulate your immune responses.
Those are the things that you're going to do
to help stimulate your lymphocyte production.
So there isn't really anything else that you could do
but what you're doing there.
Can you please tell me the time when I can take alpha-lopeic acid
for my neuropathy when I'm doing chemo?
So alpha-lopeic acid is one of your stronger antioxidants
that you cannot take during that 48 hours.
So that's the whole thing.
So if you're doing chemo infusions on Monday at 9 o'clock
and you're done at 11 o'clock on Monday,
do not take alpha-lopeic acid until 11 o'clock on Wednesday.
So just those 48 hours post chemo
is when you have to lay off an alpha-lopeic acid,
otherwise you can take it.
So I note with the neuropathy,
you also need to consider B6.
B6 can be very beneficial for neuropathy.
Also, I know if you're not using a rebuilder for neuropathy,
that can be really helpful.
That's a little electronic device that we sell to our patients
less than what we're supposed to on our website.
So look at using a rebuilder as well.
And definitely make sure you're doing the eye and throw away.
That will be helpful for neuropathy as well.
Feel like I'm getting bloated when I drink my green juices.
Do cover lettuce salad or try to drink 16 to 20 ounces a day,
four times a day, too much.
There's a tightening issue.
If you're getting bloated with anything,
it can be because you have an HCL deficiency.
So, however, we've talked a lot about the need
for hydrochloric acid in your stomach.
So, hydrochloric acid in your stomach
is how you're gonna digest a lot of these green drinks
that's, I mean, hydrochloric acid helps with proteins,
but mainly with carbohydrates.
And when we have a deficiency in HCL,
we're not properly digesting them
and that it goes into the small intestine less than fully digesting
and it puts more burden on our pancreas and pancreatic enzymes.
And then carbohydrates will ferment to a greater degree
in a small intestine,
when they're not properly digested by HCL in the stomach,
and that will cause bloating.
So, just by using cell HCL sign,
which is a US enzymes product will often be the solution
when you only take, just take maybe one of the start
which is taking one with your largest drink.
And see if that helps.
That almost always is the fix.
Can you please clarify what trophoblasts are
and how enzymes and or products like protocell
killed trophoblasts?
Thank you very much.
So trophoblasts are, okay, so this gets a little complicated,
because trophoblasts are what technically a trophoblast
is an embryonic term, embryonic term,
that when an egg is fertilized by a sperm,
it goes through a stage that is called the trophoblasts.
And that's what attaches to the uterus wall is that trophoblast.
That's what a trophoblast is in anatomical terms.
But what this person is talking about is a trophoblast
a trophoblast was a term that was used by Dr. William Kelly
when he was describing what he thought were pre-cancerous cells.
So these were cells that were immature.
So trophoblasts comes from the Latin term trophoblast,
which means to adhere to and blasts,
which means immature cells.
So we've talked a lot about what you're especially talk about,
leukemia, the blood cancers,
you end up with a lot of blasts cells.
And those are immature white blood cells.
So in the leukemia, you're making all these immature white blood cells
that are not matured and that they don't act like mature white blood cells,
doing what mature white blood cells are going to are supposed to do.
And that's what can kill you.
You have no immune system left.
That's a mature immune system.
That's what leukemia is.
Well, trophoblast was a term that was used to describe immature cancer cells.
That is what we need to kill as these trophoblasts.
And that's what cancer really is.
That has not been a proven theory.
It's all theoretically out there in the alternative cancer world.
Though these terms have not been used for decades.
So when with Dr. William Kelly's work with enzymes,
and that's the talk about killing these trophoblasts.
So, but really how enzyme theory works
when you're taking high dose-paycreatic enzymes,
you're really not killing the cancer.
You're really killing and you're really breaking down the acidic slime layer
around a cancer so that your immune system could kill the cancer.
Enzymes do not kill cells.
So you're not, it was, that was the theory back then.
But that's been proven to be false.
Though you can't argue with it, how does enzyme therapy work then?
Well, enzyme therapy works.
And this is just my opinion because it's breaking down the acidic layer
that's created with a, when cells are in rapid replication,
there's a lot of waste that's being spilled out into the extracellular space.
That's the space between the cells.
And that actually gives the cancer cell even more ability to continue
to grow and abated because it makes it, that extra waste makes it difficult
for your immune system to get at the cancer to kill those cells.
So, enzyme therapy can help break down that waste
and leave them exposed, leave your cancer cells exposed.
That's, that's really what, so if you search for a trophoplasty,
I don't know what you find, but I think it would bring you to some embryonic description
of what a trophoplasty is in embryonic terminology.
OK, so questions that came in.
Do you think there's a value in going to a practitioner
who looks at your live blood?
I think it may be called microscopy.
It's called dark field microscopy or live cell microscopy microscopy.
There is, there's pros and cons to it.
So first of all, it's highly illegal in many states.
And then, and the reason is, is not always wrong
because a lot of dark field microscopy practitioners,
it's something you have to be fairly skilled at in order
to really get a good reading.
I think there's a lot of value in it.
I think there's benefit to it, but it's, it's not going to,
I don't know how much information you're going to get off at this time.
You certainly can go and get tested.
It's not very expensive and you could get a look at it.
I can bet it's all right.
You can't do that under even as lay person when you could,
you could get people that throw it in jail.
I know it's legal in Michigan.
I think that's about the only state.
OK, do you need to take clear dim so far as I'm and aroma clear?
Well, there's certainly some cross, there's nutrients in clear dim
that are, clear dim does have some, some of the things in it
that each one of these have.
But the concentration of the Bronco products in so far as I've
is the greatest, you know, you don't get the same amount
in the clear dim or the aroma clear.
I don't think there's any of this or a side broccoli products in the aroma
clear. And you don't get the I three C in the clear dim that you get
in the aroma clear.
So there's, there's, yeah, there's benefit to take it all three of them.
If you're trying to cut down on products, certainly we could do another
cheek swab and test that.
I was ER positive or too negative.
So BDR positive.
That's why you definitely want to be taking these types of products.
Could you provide an example of when and why would request a rifle?
So the same reason why you request a cheek swab.
So you can just check that out the cheek swab form.
It's a checkbox just, you know, some people just want to hear.
I just want to recheck, you know, I just do it as a recheck like you'd go
to the doctor for a recheck or some people will check because of symptoms.
So maybe you're having an increase amount of symptoms.
That's why you want another cheek swab test.
And that might be why you want me to check for a right testing too.
If we want to add any other frequencies, usually honestly, I test for, I make the
decision whether I'm going to change your program, even if you ask for it or not.
But, but the biggest reason why somebody would want a rifle update is if they're not doing well.
Or maybe even more common reason is that they're doing really well.
And they, you know, they're spouse, you know, sleeps in the same bed with them.
And hey, can you, you know, I'm doing really great with my husband has prostate issues.
Can you put some prostate programs in my overnight so he can, you know,
doesn't have to do it during the day.
That's another one reason why people ask for it.
Somehow US enzymes has set up a program where you can take away less.
Yes.
So we talked about that.
So the reason why you could take way less than 150 kills a day is because
they're fermented or concentrated enzyme.
Finally, the Lord has given me this verse all week for Dr. Cutters and his step really for all of us.
Exodus 14, 14 to 15, the Lord, your God, which glory before you shall fight for you.
Amen.
Thank you for praying for us.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
My heart is starting every night at
1 to 2 a.m. in the morning.
Is that a liver problem?
So, really, so
you do have an acupuncture system throughout the, that the Chinese people describe throughout the 24 hour cycle, that if you have issues at different times of the day that can be related to
organ or a meridian system.
So I'm not exactly clear on what your, what your, what do you mean by heart is starting every night.
So not positively, I'm clear with that.
Maybe you can clarify that.
We will clarify that with another one.
I have breast cancer and heard about hormone balance by Dr. Demaki.
I see that you offer these on your website.
Are there any contradictions about taking this product after hearing Dr. Berkson speak about it seemed worth considering.
I don't know who's asking this, but I don't know what your issues are certainly that would be a question that on the cheek swap test, you could ask can you check for hormone balance.
And that's another thing to answer the cheek swap question.
Prior is that many people will say, I want to take this product and I really feel glad to take this product. Can you test this.
Iron pro has renal cell carcinoma I'm wondering if we can get that program on the right without using the iron pro way.
So if it's an iron pro way program, it's usually a higher frequency that you can't do with a bolt.
So you already have all the bold renal cell carcinoma programming in your bulk program that you can put in there, but the benefit one of the benefits of iron pro wave is you can go really high on the frequency that you can't be through the ball.
So you're going to probably have to do that through the iron pro rate that that.
Dr. Cutters, the pro nobo scans can they replace a pet scan CT scan for lymphoma and some bold lesions as I have over the years gotten so many CT scans and the third pet scan watching and waiting.
Yes, they can accept you have to understand that some medical practitioners, your oncologists might not know anything about the pro nobo scans.
They're medical scans. They're in medical facilities. They're not alternative scans, but it's just a lot of a lot of medical practitioners oncologists don't keep up with the times.
So if you talk to them say I want to do this chronomo scan, they make up.
Yeah, I'm very familiar with it. Yeah, we can do that instead.
It's likely they're going to say what's that I have no idea what about it. Understand, practice doctors are are basically practitioners of the industry.
So they work for a hospital system or some medical system that governs what they can and can't do when they refer out of the system they can get in trouble and the pro nobo scans are going to most likely be out of the system.
So that's my view in the case.
So go to their website, the print over website, get the data.
And then you can print it out, bring it to your doctor talk to them or just do it yourself.
Have you heard about using low dose no trexomes for cancer. Yeah, yep. So you can do that too.
described because that's a medication. It is most of the research on low-dose
deltrucks that we've talked about this I'd like to be for. It's really a
an immune regulator. So it is more commonly used for severe autoimmune
conditions but it can be used with cancer especially if a person's immune
system is really really hindered. That's where you get back to that. This would be
an option for that person back here where try to get your lymphocytes up. That
would you can't get your lymphocytes up maybe because this person is doing
chemo or something like that. That would low-dose deltrucks that would be
something that if if I was in that situation that I would consider. There's
really no side effects that I know with low-dose deltrucks. Typically it's
given at a little bit higher dose than 0.5. Typically you start out at 1.5
milligrams and for a few weeks then you move to three and then you move to 4.5
milligrams. That's the typical dosage progression of LDN but you can talk to a
practitioner that would order that for you. Any compounded local lab won't
can get that for you. Artemisinin is also very good for cancers or a big fan of
Artemisinin. That's one of the things we always test for. My speakers were
working when you were flying to the Budway question. We didn't really have a
Budway question. Can you continue the Budway? Yep, the Budway absolutely. You
can continue to if you're feeling a bit of inflammation. Remember any of these
like the Budway that would be a good thing to pulse. Meaning like okay I
gonna go off for a week and see if the inflammation goes down and your gut
calms down a little bit. Ever there's still dairy in the Budway. I don't care
what Budway practitioners say that the fact changes the dairy and still a dairy
and you're still gonna have growth hormones in the cottage cheese with the
Budway. So it's good to pulse that. Go off of it for a week and go back on. We
answered this about the eczema. I would consider finding a practitioner that
uses laser and try laser on your eczema. I just say this from my experience years
ago. We're one of the first clinics that used laser at that time. It was level 2B
laser and we had really good results with people with eczema. Do you think red
light infrared pads do better than infrared panellon? I think red light therapy it
yeah can be can be really good. So yes if you had access to both I would do
definitely both. You could also do light red light therapy for eczema. Another good
tool for eczema that I have not used for eczema but I would consider it for
eczema is this other tool that I have spoken very little about that we just
got recently. It's these really neat little head held light therapy units. And I
have to search for it because I can't remember the name of them. It's the
Visum light. So right here. Visum light little tools we have on our store. They're
still expensive. There are a couple thousand dollars. But I did an interview our
podcast with the gal who invented these really exciting. We brought several of them
to use for our patients. And I haven't been able to spend a whole lot of time
playing with them. But this would be another tool for eczema. She did I do really
like her. She doesn't make these you know some of these companies that sell this
stuff make all these claims that are just not removable. I just really like
everything other website. We have these in the store. Heart is resting and it's
waking me up at 1 to 2 a.m. Thank you. Also you got to consider the thing that
spikes at one or two o'clock in the morning is your cortisol. So your cortisol
daily rhythm cortisol is a horrible that's produced by your adrenal glands and it spikes
about one or two a.m. in the morning for the purpose of breaking down glycogen stores in
your liver into glucose to keep your brain alive. So if you're under a lot of stress you're
going to have issues with that and you will be waking up at 1 or 2 in the morning because
you have a deficiency of cortisol production in your needles because you're under a lot
of stress. So do examine that and get on an adapted gym for this zone. If this was me
I would start taking an adapted gym. So you know one of this if I you know did have cancer
you said well would be the one supplement if you were stranded on a desert aisle that
you would take with you it would be adaptogens. And because adaptogens help balance your hormones
that I'm talking about your pituitary, your thyroid, your needles which really give you all
your energy during the day. Help balance glucose levels. Now there are several good adaptogens.
Probably one of my favorites is the adaptogens R3 by Biong Preview Research Lab. That has
just been a wonderful proven standby. That's this product right there. That's what I would
get on if I were you look at your stress levels trying to diminish that as best you can
to. I just checked the right programs. There is no readle cell carcinoma. Of course there's no
readle cell carcinoma in your right programs. I wrote that into your overnight program. You
will not find that in your right programs. That's in your overnight program that I created for you.
I heard cycling digestive enzymes in the Kelly protocol is beneficial. Should I consider doing this
too? Yeah. I do think that can be beneficial too. It's always good to do that pulsing of different
supplements different times too. Same thing with your diet. Some people get in the habit of eating the
exact same thing all the time. And that's not always good. You know, I just I believe that we were
created to eat in season. You know, apples are in season in the fall. We eat on a lot of apples for
two, three, four months. And then you don't eat apples. And then so you're you're kind of cycling
your diet that I think there's there's a lot of benefit to that that we haven't even discovered yet.
So think about that as well. Okay. So reminder for those that jumped out late,
cheek swabs testing is available. If you have cheek swabs at home still you can send those in.
Just please print off the form that you guys have been doing most of you. So then you tell me what you
want to test. There really isn't any changes as far as the testing goes and what we could do.
I just you'll notice that I just have to word it differently. What I send you the email.
I just have to say consider this and set up. Here's the results. Do this.
That's the only thing. So you'll notice on the home page of the member site as well as the
bider and cheek swab page as well as the testing page. You have that cheek swab
testing request form. Just print that out and write out there what you want me to test for. There's
also a link down to pay for the testing and underneath that there's a button you can click on to order
more cheek swabs there free. You can just put that in to your cart. Next time you place an order
to get three cheek swabs and stuff like that. I also called Pernuvo. You can check the box where
outside doctor to write the skin. Absolutely. You don't need a doctor's referral to go to Pernuvo.
What I was talking about Mark was that if you're under your oncologist care and you want them to look
at that scan and approve it for your watch and wait thing then you then you might have to argue
with your oncologist but if you're like forget him or I'm just going to do this myself or be watching
myself they will reveal when you do the Pernuvo scan they will they will set up a time I believe
that you could talk to the radiologist their radiologist and go over your results and they have a
really nice printout of everything so we've had numerous patients do the Pernuvo and they really
like it. It's just really a nice readout and everything so you're going to enjoy that.
The only negative is that you're laid there for a long time during the scan. When I did my scan
I was not feeling well at all. I was having a lot of pain and it was torture for me to do it because
I was not well at the time but actually you know I that's what showed the regression of my cancer
and just some lesions on my liver at the time so it was very exciting results so I trust that
more than I trusted MRI or a CT scan so. All right with that I will say goodbye thank you guys
for all your prayers. No one that were prayed for you all the time and thank you also for all
the people that like emailed me personally and oh I did want to give you an update on
and Ashley so Ashley had a baby a lot of you don't know Ashley if you were working with her but she
hasn't she had a baby she's not going to come back to the clinic right now she's going to be
beat him up and which is wonderful and a blessing to this cutest little thing you've ever did see
this little baby girl that she had and Ann is taking some time off. Her son is going through
three very rigorous rounds of chemo. Talked about it a little bit before
she's doing a pediatric protocol of chemo. This will be prayed for her and AJ her son with a cute
binary in leukemia but she's going to just take some time off and will reassess
baby in six months or so. So we cherish your prayers we're all praying for you and know that we
just care for you guys and love you guys and we'll talk to you next week and I'll give you
information on the next I don't know if it'll be next Monday because we have several staff that
are going on the child next week probably the following Monday will start with that of the
thirties who'll call again okay bye bye